hello hello I've come here today to
visit my friend Jack Howard friend I
might be involved in this and so I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna ask you some
questions
based on these questions we're gonna
figure out something about us is it
gonna be who's the bigger spider-man fan
to take long to it isn't it it's not
who's the biggest fan okay it's who
would be the best spider-man oh damn oh
man
you said to me when we were eating
earlier I think you can get quite a
doozy a stink about it you have no idea
I'm going to answer these is on it's
obviously impossible yeah okay
are you afraid are you afraid of spiders
I am if I see like a big one like I've
had a big one call in my shoulder ones
totally freaked me out look at me now
that's just you're hungry
oh she said that was scary but generally
I'm not I'm not afraid of them
spider-man like spiders surely I feel
like if I had spider powers I feel I'm
one with the spiders exactly everything
that's a bit pocketing then fine I'm
appointment potentially incredibly
horrible question have any of your
significant others died don't think so
no I could remember okay and if your
center fielders died not that I'm aware
of
I could try and call now citizen update
that's not funny
it's gonna be easy to cut around your
laughter sorry do you take pictures of
yourself for work yeah yeah that's what
spy remembers yes
there you go I'd like to give you one
and a half points for that one cuz you
take a lot of selfies sure do you want
to admit that you take a lot of selfies
and give yourself a half point oh yeah
okay there we go
are you into photography yeah I like to
take pictures not just selfies how about
you is that something you do I'm big on
like Kent photography right now I feel
like if I went through your phone it
would be nothing but different angles of
your cat's I could probably fit together
like a 3d model your backgrounds your
kidneys
that's a very good picture by cat that's
pretty good
there was one photo that Emily sent me
I'll show you to you Wow doesn't that
look like a nude very different to do in
spite of yeah very little do you need
glasses
let's see whose prescription is what is
that is that what is there the pointer
in him oh yeah oh yeah I feel like we're
pretty even to be honest actually that's
what we've learned points for both of us
do you believe in the theory of the
multiverse I'd like to I don't think I
do I really like to think about that and
believe that and that if I've made a
choice that I don't like I like to think
that there's someone out there who is in
exactly the same position as me but they
made the choice that I wanted to make
but I don't know for sure that neither
side I think it exists as a storyline in
spider-man where that happens is bloody
rubbish do we get points but I thought
we take a point off spider-man but if
there's one very spider-man do you have
many enemies no one's trying to kill me
I might make some enemies by saying this
but I can usually think I'm just kind of
too nice a person to have any enemies
arrogant I haven't one enemy now so I
get a point no no I were you popular in
school not really I think it was just
always the thing where people kind of
knew who I was but normally bullied me
it was kind of sat in the middle yeah I
kind of feel like I was one of the
invisible kids in school people knew who
I was but nobody thought I was cool I
don't think I was called in school like
I've done think I was called at all we
were very cool now aren't we saying here
talking about which one of us will make
a best man yes do you have a instinctive
sense for danger yes love going high
love jumping off stuff swimming pools if
there's a Ledge I want to do a corkscrew
off it's not quite a way I meant what
you mean I mean like he's spidey
sense so it can sense danger or anything
bad boy did where's your like yeah I
love danger right in there are you
clumsy generally no okay I think I am so
I think I'm gonna give you a point
brilliant
final scores Jake you've got 13 points
and I got 16 and a half and not aware
the bottom spider-man minus one what
we've seen today is that yes I will
probably make a better spider-man feel
free to disagree in the comments I feel
like this is all our conversation is
going to be like in the future
use text images like yeah buy one on
this one so this may not be the end but
for now I won my own game so thank you
very much you're welcome seem pretty
disappointed I am very disappointed
arleigh please subscribe to Jack Howard
because it will make it feel a little
bit better about what went down here
today slightly I'll see you next time
good bye bye you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
thank you very much for watching it's me
kitchen if you have not cooked if you
want to see Charlie's previous video you
can see that at a top it's all about me
Gideon and if you want to see the
outtakes I'll surround go crazy if you
want to see the outtakes for this video
a Charlie and Jack it's e-detective
bottom sounds boring I watch the video
about me personally thank you very much
goodbye